So, welcome to the final examination.
Before I start, I want to
I want to thank the people. Uh, first of
all, I'd like to thank
Alan and Vincent for being in this class
all year long.
Uh, you have been consistent and
hard-working
uh, throughout the year. So, thank you
very much. I'm sorry if now and then I
lose my temper. Um,
but I've really appreciated your
dedication. I've really appreciated uh,
the questions you've asked in this
class.
I would I would like to thank the school
for giving me this platform and this
classroom and this smart board for the
past 4 years. Believe it or not, but
I've been here for 4 years in this
classroom. Uh,
the school has been very generous to me
letting me teach whatever I want.
Including the great books, including
geo-strategy, including game theory,
including
uh, secret history. I'll be leaving the
school at the end of this week. So, this
is my second last class. Tomorrow will
be my last class. Um, the reason why I'm
leaving the school is I feel that
I have a global audience and I want to
grow this global audience by grow grow
out grow out into the world and engaging
people outside in the world. So, I want
to focus more on my global audience.
But, I've been very thankful uh,
to the school. And uh,
third and last thing I would I would
like to thank my Substack community.
Um, so most of my income this past year
has come from Substack.
The subscribers have been very generous
uh, to me. Because of the generosity,
I've been able to keep my YouTube free
of monetization. I've been able to avoid
sponsors. I've been able to s-
I've just been able to focus on my
teaching, on the quality of my teaching.
And so,
I would like to thank the founding
members today by
by first of all point out their
generosity, but also by answering their
questions.
Starting next
week, I will do a monthly
Substack live stream with both founding
members as well as paid subscribers. So,
once a month it'll be founding members
and then once a month it will also be
paid subscribers. I'll I'll talk more
about that later on, okay? So, this is
the end of one journey, but the
beginning of another journey. And
don't worry, I will continue doing what
I do because I love teaching, I love
sharing my ideas with the world, I love
learning. And I I want to be doing this
for the next 50 years. That's my
ambition to structure it so that I can
continue to influence people for the
next 50 years.
All right. So, let's start the fun
examination. So, first of all, what what
I'm going to do is I'm going to read all
the questions from the founding members
on Substack. There's a lot and after
that, we will look at some questions
from YouTube that my wife, uh who is
here today doing the filming, I also
need to thank my wife for
um filming
uh and editing
uh this class.
Um she's here and she's helped me pick
out some questions.
And it's pretty random. So, I So, I
apologize if uh your question was not
picked, but there was just too many
questions and uh for the sake of time,
we just picked a few. But, we'll
probably run over time today, okay? Just
just a warning. All right, so let's
start. So, this is from
Noemi.
Um
and he or she just says, "I don't have a
question,
but just a thank you. And this is the
name of the Obegan Twitch which you sent
her,
Nomina.live.
And
this person is also working to raise
consciousness. So, thank you so much for
your generosity. All right, now we move
to Karina. And Karina says
that based on my lectures, it seems the
US is pretty screwed. Yes.
They need to They need to other
countries to buy US treasuries. Yes.
Israel's not loyal. Israel probably
wants to work with other countries to
establish their petrodollar. Yes. Okay.
Russia's trying to make the dollar
collapse and trying to exert its own
dominance as well as protect its own
people. Yes.
And China's just trying to figure out
what is in its best advantage. Okay? So,
that's what geopolitics is. It's a It's
a It's a game. Everyone's just looking
for the optimal strategy. There's no
loyalty. There are no friends. Okay?
It's just a game.
All right. So, the US is currently in a
race to make these AI data centers.
Um
and they need to control population.
Yes. Okay? So, there are three
questions.
What are we to do?
I I understand we should build
communities, but what does this look
like? Pretty much anyone who has US
dollars would be in a world of hurt. I
mean, how would we buy food? What do you
think our world will look like? Okay.
So, it's hard for you to predict what
the world will look like because it it
hasn't happened yet.
All right. It's important to have game
theory in mind because it gives you the
over structure of the world. But it's
also important to remember that we
create the world that we want.
All right. So, let's just say tomorrow
there's no more electricity.
It doesn't mean that we start taking
knives, start killing each other. What
it means is that we change mentality
because the circumstances of our lives
have changed. So, we start caring about
each other more. So, what happens is
maybe before in your apartment complex,
you didn't know your neighbor. The
lights go out all out. So, what you do
is you open the door and you go meet
your neighbors and say, "Hey, let's
figure this out." Okay? So, the thing to
keep in mind is that fundamentally, we
humans are extremely creative, extremely
resilient. And the spark in us hasn't
activated yet. But in the circumstances
that are required of us, we will become
creative. And this has been true
consistently throughout human history.
So, what we need to do is recognize that
what makes us who we are are our
creativity, our resilience,
our empathy, our imagination. This is
who we are really. And the idea that we
are economic machines or economic tools,
that all we care about is buying stuff
and making money, that's just
a indoctrination that we have to suffer
uh in recent history. Okay? So, what
really important to keep in mind is that
our greatest power is our imagination.
So, what we should be doing is working
hard to build our imagination. And that
just means
learning. Learning through books,
but also learning by listening to other
people, experiencing viewpoints that are
different from yours, and by
experiencing things in the world. Okay?
For example, traveling more.
Or [snorts]
doing things that are beyond comfort
zone.
All right.
Who do you believe would rise to the
next global power and how do you believe
they would govern the trust around the
world after such epic fall from the US
dollar? Would it would be money backed
by gold and other resources again?
Um
So, I talked about this I talked about
this before, but the US dollar as a
global reserve currency, it's a
historical accident.
And it's never happened before in human
history. And quite honestly, it probably
would never happen again in human
history. So, once the US dollar falls,
that it doesn't it does not mean that
the global economy collapses. It just
means that global reserve currency will
probably transform into a basket of
currencies, which includes US dollar,
which includes gold, which probably
would include British pounds, Swiss
francs, a basket of currencies, right?
So, people could still will continue to
trade,
but it will not be as convenient as
before.
Okay? So, and this is a process that
doesn't happen like now it's or
tomorrow. It's going to take many years,
many decades for this process to play
out.
Um is there any way to get out of the
Ponzi scheme once you're in it? This is
a really good question. The answer is
that the Ponzi scheme has collapsed
before you you can get out of it. And
basically a Ponzi scheme collapses when
the US dollar or the US government
defaults on its debt.
Okay? That's that's what a Ponzi scheme
collapse looks like. And at that point,
the US dollar is basically worth very
little or or almost nothing. It's going
to happen one day. It's just a question
of like when.
All right? And it may sound painful, but
again, we humans are actually resilient.
Just because there's no electricity,
just because we can't drive our cars,
just because we can't buy anything, does
not mean we'll starve to death. We'll
figure out a way
to survive, okay? So,
so let me give you an example where
I take 100 people from different
countries. I For whatever reason, I try
to put you all to a desert island.
Okay? It doesn't mean that you'll just
fight each other because you're from
different cultures.
It won't mean that you'll starve to
death because you don't speak the same
language. What it will mean is that
somehow, some way, the 100 of you will
create a new language and instinctually,
intuitively, understand how to work
together. You figure out that, "You know
what? I'm a good carpenter, so I'll go
make wood."
And another person like, "Well, I'm good
at singing, so I'll so I'll make songs
and entertain us at night." Okay? It
will happen very organically, it will
happen very fluently, dynamically. And
that's what makes us humans so creative,
okay? We have empathy for each other. We
don't have to speak the same language
and we're still able to work together.
All right? So, don't worry about the end
of the world, it just means a new world
comes into being.
All right?
All right.
All right, this is from His- Hidden
History Society. Okay, uh this is very
long, but to summarize, what he's saying
is that Freemasons were critical in the
in America's founding and Benjamin
Franklin
uh was a Freemason, Alexander Hamilton
uh
mother was Jewish, so he was half
Jewish, he was Scottish and Jewish as
well. And so, there was lots of these
linkages between the Freemasons, between
the Jewish faith and these founding
fathers.
And [snorts] I would say don't put too
much emphasis on this, okay? There's
going to be these overlaps, convergences
everywhere.
Doesn't mean that they're that
important.
All right?
All right.
And then he goes on and says that,
"Look, Engels and Marx congratulated
Lincoln upon his re-election and Lincoln
was a like- was a big fan of their
publications, okay?" What's that mean?
It means that people with talent, people
with ideas, respect each other. Okay? It
just means that, you know, I'm a curious
person. I'm just interested in anyone
who proposes new ideas and who does
great things and who's an interesting
person.
Okay? Doesn't mean that we're all
conspiring together. It just means that
we're all looking for new ideas. We all
respect people of talent.
All right?
>> [snorts]
>> Okay.
Basically, do you think these American
leaders were English assets and can you
explain British capital shifting America
from 19 from 1888 transatlantic period
culminating to Bretton Woods and America
taking over their empire after World War
But they have contacts in the British
Empire, of course, because because
Britain was the most powerful country at
this time. So, there's going to be a lot
of overlap.
Okay? There's going to be a lot of
shared affinities, a lot of shared
interests.
Did they have French contacts? Yes. Did
they have
um Canadian friends? Yes. All right? So,
the world of the elite is very, very
small and they they're always in contact
with each other.
All right? Um so, it is true that
British capital shifted America after
after the Civil War,
right? And this led to the
founding of the Federal Reserve, which
led to Bretton Woods.
Okay, so what happened was that
the British were getting very, very rich
off India and China,
right? So, they basically enslaved India
and de-industrialized India and char
and and they stole trillions of dollars
from India.
They enslaved China with opium. They
were stealing trillions of dollars from
China. And now what they have to do is
put this invest their money somewhere.
And the best place in the world to
invest your money at this time would be
America. You can also invest in South
America, but the Americans were much
harder harder working, they were much
more ambitious. So, a lot of the money
went to America. Now, at this time in
history, the Americans didn't like the
British because they fought a war to get
rid of the British, right? So, the idea
that you have all these trillions
trillions trillions of dollars coming
into America to to buy out America, the
Americans wouldn't have put up with
this. So, the solution was to have
agents, people like Rockefeller,
Carnegie,
Vanderbilt, disguised as entrepreneurs,
right? They were poor and through their
hard work, through their merit, they
became billionaires. And that was the
um but that they were creation of the
City of London. They were creation of
British capital in order to co-opt
America. And they were so powerful that
they were then able to influence
American politics, and then create the
Federal Reserve, which which then after
World War II led to the Bretton Woods
system, okay? So, that's what happened.
So, um this something that is still
impacting America today, and many people
who support Trump believe that Trump is
um
a Messiah figure who's come to help
America rid itself of the disease of
transaction capital, to get rid of the
British, okay? To fight another 1776.
There are millions of Americans who who
believe this, all right? And they have a
point. All right.
From Zorahad from Zorahad.
Um so, he asks, "It seems
that the world is collapsing. Is there a
way out of this collapse?"
Um
"The world is a fat person,
but is it possible for for the fat
person
to maybe work out, lose weight, and
become healthier?
Um is it possible we take this step? Um
if we can imagine, we use our
imagination, is it possible for us to
save ourselves before we kill ourselves?
And this is really good question.
And
um first of all, I would say it's
unlikely.
Okay? Because the reality is that yes,
in theory, we could change, but in
reality, you just look at look around
the people around you, most people don't
change.
Okay? I would say if all the nations of
the world, the nation that is the most
resilient, that is most creative, that
could change possibly, is America. So,
could America change? Possibly, but
it would take tremendous leadership. A
figure, a messianic figure, would arise
to rally American people in order to
change. And that I don't think is
likely. It It may happen, I hope it
happens, but I think it is very um
unlikely.
I mean, the problem with this metaphor
of an individual who thinks he's fat and
wants to change is you need to recognize
that a nation is a collection of vested
interests.
Okay? And this is this is conflict among
these vested interests, what we call
elite overproduction.
That's what leads what leads to decline.
And the And the reason why this decline
is they're so focused on their internal
conflict, they ignore the larger
picture.
And they only win if they focus on
winning. So, they're willing to do
whatever it takes to win, even if it
means the destruction of their own
civilization.
All right? They're willing to sacrifice
everything, anything, in order to win.
What is a billionaire? A billionaire is
a person who is willing to kill his own
grandmother for money, okay?
That's what a billionaire is.
All right. From
Um I I I'm sorry, I can't pronounce this
person, okay?
All right.
Um why do you never mention Vedic
eschatology? Um
It's very, very important, yes.
And Vedic thought has spread across
Europe and America through new age
collectives and movements.
Um
Do you think these will shape the world
in the coming decades?
Um I want to be overlooked them because
their eschatologies don't seem
aggressive enough to move history. Okay.
So, um one thing I want to clarify is
that the way I teach is I see learning
as a journey, okay? So, when I teach,
I'm asking questions and I'm trying to
work out the answers myself. So, it
isn't like I know all the answers and
then I'm giving you a glimpse into my
mind. That's how it works, okay? I
myself am working with certain
assumptions. I'm expanding outwards in
order to form a more general
understanding of the world. So, so this
is a very simple way So, another way of
saying this is I don't know enough about
Vedic eschatology to comment on it.
Okay? I want to know more. I will learn
more. Eventually, I will I want to make
a trip to India and learn about Vedic
eschatology. But right now, I don't know
enough about it. That's the first point.
Second point is that maybe in the
future, India will play a very important
part in geopolitics. I hope it does, but
right now, it doesn't, okay? So, Israel,
America, Russia, Iran are the four major
nations that I'm studying right now. And
so
um
um I want to expand outwards. So, first
I want to understand these four nations
and then I will expand outwards to
include India
as well, okay?
So, it's not that I am
um
it's not that I don't think highly of
Vedic eschatology. It's just like I
don't know enough about the comment I'm
making.
Uh this is from Christie.
Um what are you and your family doing
preparation for what is coming
when the world seems to be falling apart
when there's energy price,
uh food shortage, AI surveillance state?
Um well,
I have a family. My wife is here. We
have three kids.
And the answer is we're focusing on
loving each other as much as possible.
My wife and I spend most of our time
talking about our children and thinking
about how to make them happy.
Because we believe our children can be
resilient, can be imaginative. But our
responsibility as parents is to make
sure they're loved enough in the house
in the
in the time that we're with us so that
they have strength
to surmount any difficulty.
Okay? So, it So, our strategy is not to
make, you know, a billion dollars and
then build a bunker
and then hope that we we are safe in
this bunker. That gets you nowhere. Our
strategy is to have faith in our
children,
understand that
once our children grow up,
it's entirely their choice how to live
their lives. We We will not intervene.
We will not interfere in their own path.
And in the time of us, our
responsibility is to make sure there is
love as poss- as much as possible, okay?
So, that that's where our is.
Um number two,
you mentioned US wants to introduce
stable coins in China and the US will do
everything it can to keep USD valuable.
Does that mean gold is our safe haven or
store of value going forward like it has
been for hundreds of years?
Um gold, well, I don't buy gold. I don't
even want to buy gold.
Okay? The reason why is that
you're using money [clears throat]
in order to uh buy things to solve
everyday problems.
Gold is a store of value because you
obviously can't use gold to go to the
convenience store and buy a a
bottle of water. That's just
okay?
Um so, if you have a lot of money and
you have no place to put put your money,
then you should put it in gold or real
estate. The problem is imagine a world
in which there's a lot of instability,
when there's a lot of chaos, when the
population is declining. Well, in that
scenario, well, your problem isn't how
much money you have because the value of
gold is going is going to go down in
value because there's less demand,
there's less people. Your problem is how
do I maintain my faith in myself? How do
I have the strength to surmount the
psychological turmoil of chaos? How do I
find the courage to go work with other
people in order to rebuild a new world?
Okay? So, it's really about spiritual
energy as opposed to
uh material wealth.
All right, number three.
You will mention there will be a
depression after the fall of the
petrodollar, but then you mention that
the US will force China and other
countries to purchase gas from the US so
that people will keep buying US debt and
rely on the US dollar. Do you see an
economic depression happening worldwide
due to the downfall of US dollar or will
this crisis be averted due to US forcing
others
to buy its gas. Yes, I did mention the
United States has a strategy of forcing
the entire world to buy its gas and its
oil. I didn't say it was going to work.
In fact, I probably I I probably said it
did or was not going to work. Because
it's Because when you do something like
this, when you try to
control the entire world and force it to
to to do its bidding,
um it's basically blown in your face,
okay? So, yes, in theory, if the United
States forces the world to buy its oil,
then the United States could maintain
the petrodollar. The problem is that the
United States is doing this not for the
national interest. The United States is
doing this in order to promote the
interest of certain factions and
interest groups within the
American elite.
Okay? It's a very important distinction.
The The The people in charge don't care
if there's if there's an economic
depression. An An economic depression
just means that you can buy things for
really cheap.
Okay? It also means that you can enforce
an authoritarian state upon this the the
the the nation because people are will
be desperate.
So, they're doing what they're doing in
order to
um
obtain more wealth and more money for
themselves.
Right? So, Trump is doing what Trump is
doing not to save America, but to help
his friends.
And once you understand that, then you
understand there's no Just because
they're going to do this does not mean
the the United States will not collapse
economically. They don't care the United
States collapses economically.
Um
Number four, I'm from New Zealand, which
is a country that has not been mentioned
in your lectures, although all your
charts seem to show that New Zealand
will be quite badly affected by the Iran
war. Do you see New Zealand joining NATO
in the fight against Ukraine? I read
news that billionaires are building
bunkers in New Zealand. Does that mean
we will some be somewhat safe from
future conflicts? What will New Zealand
do? I'm just an everyday citizen wanting
the best for my children here.
Okay.
New Zealand is an interesting
um
because New Zealand is very much a
Canada
and Australia. Okay, these three places:
New Zealand, Australia, Canada. They're
not nation-states. They are resource
colonies of the British Empire.
All right? Meaning that they are owned,
literally owned by the British.
So, their resources, their wealth
belongs to the British. And so, what's
happening in these countries right now
is a corporate restructuring where the
population is being replaced.
All right? The populations there have
become lazy,
complacent. And so, they're importing
millions of new immigrants, primarily
Indians, but also a lot of Chinese, a
lot of Filipinos, to replace the
population because
in a time of economic decline, you need
your colonies to perform better. All
right? So, I don't see New Zealand
participating in any wars, but I do see
New Zealand, the population being
replaced by immigrants.
Okay? And this will probably lead to a
lot of
um civil conflict in these places.
All right?
Uh from Demi.
Uh you mentioned
how before how you used to live with
your parents, play video games, and feel
disconnected from the world. What is
your typical book, philosopher, or work
of art that inspired you towards the
path you're on now? What concrete advice
do you have for young men who feels
aimless and nihilistic who want to get
back on a spiritually productive
path? Okay, this is a really hard
question for me to answer. Yes, it is
true that in my late 20s I was very
depressed and I felt that life was
hopeless and
um
and I feel as though
you have to go through stages like this
in your life.
So, it's not something to be avoided.
It's something that you'll have to
suffer through. And when you when you
hit rock bottom, you instinctively or
intuitively understand that I need to
move on with my life, okay? So, during
this during this time period, what I did
was I engaged in a period of
self-reflection in which I questioned my
assumptions about the world. I went to
Yale University and after I went to Yale
University, I thought the world was
meritocratic. It was logical
that if you worked hard, if you have
talent, then you succeed in life. And
and then after floundering through life
uh in my 20s, I had many years where I
became very depressed and I just thought
and thought about my own life and I
recognized that I need to have a better
understanding, a more nuanced
understanding of how the world works.
And this led me to the journey that has
led me to today, okay? So,
failure is not something to be ignored
or avoided or be to be feared. It's
something to be embraced.
Okay, don't fear failure.
If there's a work that has had the most
influence in me on me these past 10, 20
years, it would be Dante's The Divine
Comedy, okay? But that's very hard to
read. Um
so, in mid-June,
I will teach a two-week seminar line by
line
uh close reading of Dante's The Divine
Comedy.
And what I'm hoping to do is inspire
people to engage in their own
self-reflection and to think much more
deeply about their own uh purpose in
this world, okay? And ho- hopefully this
will help in the future.
If I'm Alex,
um I don't
I don't disagree with the notion that AI
is an occult project, but I find there's
a curious
similarity between what you call the
occult and the sentiment of courage that
a scientist or inventor must have in
pursuing the development of some
revolutionary technology that they truly
believe is a benefit for humanity. I
don't disagree with it. I think that if
you want to be a true scientist, your
imagination must involve the occult. If
you're a great scientist like Isaac
Newton was, you're not interested in
like creating a patent or an invention
that will make you a billion dollars.
You don't care about that. You want to
know the mind of God. You want to change
the world forever. That's what leads to
tremendous
inspiration and imagination.
Your lecture
on the Holy Empire of AI interpreted the
quote from Peter Thiel's Zero to One as
an invitation to start a secret society
to access the occult as a way to
dominate the world. I don't necessarily
disagree with your interpretation.
However, I find a similarity between the
passage you quote from Thiel and another
book called The Hero with a Thousand
Faces by Joseph Campbell. Exactly.
Exactly. So, all these heroic figures in
history, they've all have similar
characteristics. They all believe that
they are on a mission, a secret mission
from God, and they must create a
movement around them in order to advance
humanity. Yes.
Um
Okay.
Yes.
Um I don't disagree with your intuition
in particular about lumping the occult
and society, world dominance, religion,
and AI into one basket. You then point
out that all true innovation is occult
in nature. I completely agree with this.
You have to understand the occult if you
want to be innovative. That's why I
teach it. And the occult is agnostic to
whether your intention is to access it
for the benefit of mankind or to access
it with an intention intention to
dominate the the world. Exactly. Um
so when I teach tonic, I teach people
like God has given us free will. Free
will means you can do good, you can do
evil. Does he doesn't care, okay?
Doesn't matter.
Uh for what and
it just happens that the most visible
tech voices seem to have used technology
dominate the world. This is exactly
correct, okay?
So
people who are truly innovative
there's a diversity among them, but the
people who will succeed are those who
are most aligned with power and control.
Okay? So if you love making money,
then guess what? You'll be successful.
But if you want to help help humanity,
guess what? You won't be successful,
okay? So there's almost like a like a
direction to history. If you follow that
direction, you almost like a right away
to power. So people who are extremely
greedy like, you know, Mark Zuckerberg,
Steve Jobs, Larry Ellison, they'll be
much more successful than people like me
who is much more interested in educating
people, okay? And that's the reality of
the world we live in, but the thing to
remember is that um God wanted this way
because only by giving us complete free
will
can we be truly imaginative, all right?
And I could be doing what
I'm doing unless there were evil people
like Mark Zuckerberg doing what he's
doing, all right? So
all right? So um
what's important is the free will.
All right. So
Alan, can you help can you help me read
this, please?
>> Okay.
A question from a 21-year-old American
male. Do you believe that American draft
is still coming, Professor Zhang? Many
young American men follow you and those
who are willing to take drastic action
are left wondering what direction to go.
If a draft is still coming, is it worth
fleeting the US this summer? Do you have
any general addition advice for young
men? Thank you.
>> Okay. Uh first of all, I do believe the
draft is coming. But not only that, but
I believe that the draft is coming to
many countries including Canada,
Australia,
Europe. And you think that the purpose
of a draft is to fight a war.
But you think about about deeply, the
purpose of a draft is to reorganize
society in a certain way. So, in America
today, what do young men do? Well, they
buy Bitcoin, they gamble online, they're
on OnlyFans.
They don't want to work because the pay
is too low.
And this is a disaster for the country.
Young men go to college and for 4 years
they
drink beer and watch football games.
And they don't learn anything, right?
So, you have this huge
social problem on your hands that young
men are effec- aren't contributing
effective to your economy.
So, what you do is you enter near
financial crisis like the Great
Depression so that you're forced to work
because your parents have no more money.
And then you have an actual draft to
teach you skills that you will need in
order to contribute more effectively to
the economy, okay? So, a draft doesn't
necessarily mean that you go to war. A
draft just means that you work for the
government for like 5 to 10 years. It's
possible like they make they train you
to be an engineer in the Navy. Believe
it or not, but the best education you
can possibly receive is often from the
military because
unlike schools, they're incentivized to
actually teach you something useful.
Okay? And it's often for free.
So,
um a draft is something that they they
they need in order to basically train
young men to be effective contributors
to the economy. And it's something that
many countries will adopt as well. If
you If you let young men do what they
want, they're just going to play video
games,
spend all their money on OnlyFans,
and gamble everything on Bitcoin, okay?
And they don't really know anything
useful.
So, this is a huge problem, and that's
why they need a national draft to fix
this problem. So,
should you run away if there's a draft?
I I just told you there's no place to
run to, okay? Either you go to a nation
with a draft, or you you go to a nation
which has even worse problems, like
famine, okay? So, I mean, what's
important is to recognize that the world
is changing.
You're not going to We're not going to
go back to the old world.
Things are not going to stay the same,
and so you must embrace change.
All right? A national draft means that
if you're useful,
they'll keep you alive. If you're not
useful, they'll send you to your uh
where you'll die, okay? That's what it
means. So, make yourself useful. Read
books. Learn skills.
Work hard. Okay, that's my advice. I'm
sorry I'm sorry to be so blunt, but
that's just the world we live in, okay?
All right.
Uh John Zack says, "Thank you." Well,
thank you, John Zack. All right. Uh can
can you read Macquell?
Um
Alan?
>> Professor, what is your take on the uh
cat and AI design to bypass the false
optimization minimum of human
extinction? Instead of forcing a stereo
piece, it would optimize for minimum
conflict energy and maximize creativity
creative collaboration. By structurally
limiting the harm capacity capacity of
non empath- empathetic actors, could
such a framework successfully steer
humanity's historical traject-
trajectory toward healthy, constructive
competition without violating our
autonomy.
>> Yeah, that's a great point. It is
possible for AI to do this. The question
is, who's going to pay for this?
Right? If you're a billionaire, the
reason why you invest in AI is to have
more money to extend your power and your
wealth.
And that means to control people better,
right?
So, then I have to create AI system.
That means you don't need government
anymore. Government's going to invest in
this in order to have more control of
people. Okay, so that's the issue that
we face. The reality is that AI is very
expensive. You need trillion dollar data
centers in order to run AI effectively.
Okay? All right, can can you
read, Alan?
>> Thank you for your work, Professor. In
an upcoming multipolar world order, do
you think the general
populace, especially American, is
prepared or even capable of making the
mental shift and understanding just how
much the world is shifting? Or is this
something the next generation will only
understand?
>> Yeah, this is a great question, and
unfortunately, the reality is that most
people will not be able to make this
mental shift, especially older people.
That's why most people are going to die.
You're not able to make the shift,
you're going to die.
Okay? Because you'd rather die than
accept the new reality.
And it's unfortunate, but a lot of the
conflicts are going to come from the
fact that the world is changing.
People in society need to make changes
to adapt to this new world. For example,
if there's energy shortages, that means
we need to share more. There's not
enough energy to go around, guys, but it
means you need to share more. It means
you have to make personal sacrifices to
make sure that your neighbor has enough
to eat. And unfortunately, there's going
to be a lot of people, especially baby
boomers, who are built who are
millionaires. Now, I'm not saying I'm
not I'm not all baby boomers are
millionaires. I'm saying that baby
boomers are poor millionaires. They're
extremely selfish. They They're not
going to want to make these changes.
They're not going to want to pay more
taxes or give up their million-dollar
mansions so that the world can be
better.
Okay? And we know this because if they
were willing to do this, we wouldn't be
in this mess in the first place.
So, a lot of conflict is going to come
from the fact that you have people in
power who will be stubborn,
who will be too old to change,
and who will be violent in resisting
change.
Okay? All right. Uh can I keep on going?
>> Hi, Professor. Can you tell a story
about one of the times you felt really
connected to the monad and what insight
did did give you? Love the lessons. A
big hug to you and your family. Take
care.
>> Okay. So, there are many many instances
where I felt connected to the monad.
But, when I teach, I feel connected to
the monad. It's a very strange
experience. But, you know, the first
time I started teaching was like when I
was like 20 years old. I was in China. I
was not a very good teacher. But, when
I'm teaching and the students are
learning, I can feel them learning, I
feel as though we connect back to the
monad. Okay? So, the most gratifying
gratifying experience I have is when I
teach and I see students
um
edify by the teaching. When I see
students learning.
Okay? That is direct connection to the
monad. When you love someone, like I
love my wife, I feel connected to the
monad. When I hug my child, when I have
a newborn, I hug them my newborn for the
first time, that's connection to the
monad. So, the monad is with us all the
time. It's just do we choose to connect
with it or not.
Okay? If you just listen to your heart,
um then
you can easily connect to to the monad.
Connection to the monad is the greatest
happiness in the world. So, moments of
greatest happiness in our world are when
when we hug someone we love.
Okay? When we care for a friend. Your
friend is sick and in a hospital, but
you spend
2 weeks just by the bedside of your
friend. Is that a Is that a feeling of
pain or pleasure? I think for most
people it's it's a feeling of deep
pleasure that you're helping someone,
that you're contributing to the world
positively.
Okay?
All right.
Keep on going?
>> Yeah, okay.
Professor John, many discussions around
AI focus on surveillance, government
control, censorship, and manipulation.
But, what if that is only the surface
layer? As AI, social media algorithms,
governments, collective emotions, and
human consciousness begin recursively
interacting with one another, it feels
like we are entering an era where
reality itself become fragmented and
amplified simultaneously. Not just fake
news, but entire emotion and
psychological ecosystem shaking how
different groups perceive truth,
identity, memory, and meaning. In the
future, do you think humanity risk
losing a shared consen- consensus
reality altogether? And if so, what
anchors human consciousness will when
billions of people are each interacting
with different AI mirrors trained on
different values, narratives, and
emotions feedback loops?
At that point, is AI merely a tool of
civilization or does it become part of
civilization's involving consciousness
itself?
>> Okay. So, there's a very famous Canadian
media theorist named Marshall McLuhan.
And his famous saying is, "The medium is
the message." And the idea here is that
the medium itself, whether it's radio or
television or the internet, it shapes
the way you perceive yourself and the
world. So, you look at ChatGPT.
In theory, chat GPT is supposed to
enhance your imagination because chat
GPT is able to reduce the grunt work,
right? It's able to provide you all
information and then you're able to
build on top of this information. But in
reality, what happens is that people
become reliant on chat GPT and you lose
your imagination, okay? Chat GPT is not
going to make you smarter, it makes you
dumber.
So, why is that? And the answer is the
monad. What makes you smart, what gives
you your creativity, is your constant
connection to the monad. So, if you
shift your focus from technology and
away from your
uh intuition, then you're going to lose.
Okay?
But
why we have why we have chat GPT, why
why we why we have AI is it's a way to
structure your thinking in a way that
allows the powers that be to control you
better.
All right?
Okay? So, remember this idea that all
technology in a way reduces your
connection to the monad. And therefore,
all technology is bad in a certain way.
Doesn't mean it's useless, but it means
it's going to deepen your connection to
the monad. What strengthens your
connection to the monad is
other people.
All right? And yourself. So, if you
really want to be creative, if you
really really want to explore and
understand humanity, take long walks in
the park, talk to strangers,
read a lot of books.
Okay?
All right, let's keep on going.
>> Question, how do you define beauty and
how should general public members
purchase pursue beauty in the current
world?
>> Beauty is the divine.
Okay? Beauty is connection to the
divine. Beauty is a glimpse into
the divine. Beauty are the sparks
that are prominent [snorts]
throughout the world.
Okay?
And so, beauty are experiences that
change you for the better
because they shock you into a new
reality. And so, beauty would include
the great books, Homer, Dante. It could
It could include an experience that you
have that forever changes you, okay?
That's how how I would I would define
beauty.
All right. Uh can I go on?
>> Great to be part of this. I have several
questions. Please pick whatever you
like.
>> right. All right. All right.
Let me just pick one random, okay?
Um
Um what happens if Saudi Arabia says I'm
building its new pipeline? Uh no. Well,
you know, then Iran will just blow it
up, okay, guys? It's a desert.
Okay? You have to build things in a
desert. It's pretty easy to blow things
up in a desert. There's There's no place
to hide. Pipelines are very easy to blow
up because there's all energy inside,
right? Just a ballistic missile, boom,
that thing is blown up. All right?
Okay.
All right.
Uh let's go to Shelley.
>> You have [snorts] discussed Pax Pax
Judaica many times. The idea of Israel
as the center hub of a new regional
order, but Pax Silicon reframes Israel
as merely a node in the broader US-led
technology and supply chain
architectures, not the dominant power.
What is your take on Pax Silicon?
>> Okay. All right. So,
Pax Judaica is Israel is is at the
center of Middle East, okay?
Pax Silicon, the idea is that
artificial intelligence,
um backed by silicon, is the new world
power. The problem with Pax Silicon is
that it's really a trade network. Now,
trade networks are often very, very
fragile. Trading networks requires the
cooperation of different nation-states
to maintain its coherence.
And what we know from history is that
power comes from the nation-state. Okay?
So, unless you have a nation-state
backing Pax Silicon, it's not going to
work. So, you can you can say that
behind Pax Silicon will be Pax Judaica.
That's a possibility.
But,
then Pax Judaica is in charge, okay? Not
Pax Silicon.
All right?
So, the idea that you can have an
independent, autonomous trading system
to produce AI, it can't work. Okay?
Ultimately, you need a nation-state to
back it with military power, with
resources, with people.
All right. Okay, let's keep on going
with Isaiah.
>> Awesome day, John and wife. Thanks for
the love you have shared together to
create such treasured treasured content
and family. I'm going to list some
topics
uh and Qs, and I'd like to know the most
important things you'd like to share
about each one you choose.
One, unconditional love. Two, the good
side of Kabbalah.
Three uh third, three, non-dual
awareness. Four, fertilized crisis.
>> All right. Sorry. Sorry. I'm sorry. This
is like way too long. I appreciate the
question, but this this this is going to
take too long, okay? So, let let me just
look look at the top two. I'm going to
do love. Unconditional love is something
that once you achieve it, it changes you
forever, okay? And you basically achieve
unconditional love when you have a child
for the first time.
Because you have to love your child
unconditionally. Because a child is
about experience, okay?
Uh the good side of Kabbalah, there are
many good sides of Kabbalah. I don't
understand why Kabbalah is put in such a
negative
um light. But, Kabbalah it's a really
it's a very powerful way of
understanding the world and forces you
to think very deeply about your place in
the world. Look, the reality is that if
you go to American University,
there are two ethnic groups that are
pretty dominant in academia in America.
They are the Indians and the Jews. The
Indians have a Vedic tradition, the Jews
have a Kabbalah tradition. This is not
an accident, okay?
If you want uh like if you really want
to be creative, and we've said this in
the past, you need to understand the
occult. The Kabbalah forces you to
wrestle with the occult,
and recognize that beyond the material
world, there are these deep mystical
questions that can guide your life. And
by dealing with these
questions, not only will it help you
better understand your place in the
world, but they also advance your own
scientific inquiry.
Okay?
>> [snorts]
>> All right. Uh
Okay. Can you keep up with me, boy?
>> Yeah.
>> Just just read this. My question is,
what do you think?
>> Yeah. My question is, what do you think
of the Yuga cycle, and according to
universal laws, why do you institutions
like the Roman Empire to exist? The
Kabbalah speaks of Earth being a center
figure forge, essentially the Earth
being cycles upon cycles upon cycles,
Fibonacci sequence,
uh samsara, etc.
>> Stop, okay, all right. So, this is a
really important idea where for 1,000
years, humans have come to an
understanding, which is the world works
in cycles. You rise, you fall. You live,
you die. There's summer, there's winter.
There's nothing you can do about this.
What is hubris? What is stupid? What is
arrogant? It's a belief that you can
stop history. You can end history.
And that can only lead to destruction,
okay? So, that's So, that's the world
live in today where
it is natural for the American empire to
decline
and to go away. That's just That's just
human history. That's just a cycle.
But, there's suffering because the
American empire refuses to go away. It
refuses to die.
And therefore, we must suffer, okay?
But, there's nothing that you can do
about this. The more you resist, the
greater the pain, the quicker the fall.
Okay? And this is something that all
religions teach us. Just accept the life
cycle.
Okay? Saying that empires decline is the
same as saying that an earthquake is
coming.
Okay? Can you stop an earthquake coming?
No. You just have to prepare for it. An
empire decline, same thing. It's just a
natural cycle.
Okay? All right.
This is from Sarah.
>> Yeah.
Date noted. I'm very interested in the
live streams. I hope it is the basics
for the school you would like to build
up. I'm going to be present thinking of
good question for the last class. Thank
you.
>> Yeah. Great. So, yeah, exactly. I'm very
excited about our first live stream,
which is scheduled for next Sunday at
9:00 a.m. 9:00 a.m. in Beijing time.
That'd be like 9:00 p.m. in New York on
the East Coast. Um I understand that
there'll be many people around the world
who are not able to participate in the
live stream, especially people from
Europe, okay? But, the idea is that
we'll change the timing of the live
stream as time goes by, okay?
In order to accommodate more people.
But, uh Sarah is absolutely right. I'm
doing this in order to in order to to
form the basis of a school community.
And this is all experiment, but but
we'll try the first live stream
um next Sunday, June 7th, okay? So, uh
so I'll send a note to all founding
members that we'll be doing this live
stream as as an experiment. And then And
then after June 7th, uh a week later,
I'll do a live stream for all paid
subscribers on Substack. All live
streams will be eventually uploaded to
my YouTube channel, so you so no one
will miss the content. But
But during the live stream, only
founding members or paid subscribers
will be able to participate, okay?
All right. Keep on going.
>> Uh hello, Professor. I want to begin by
saying your lectures have given me an
under
Oh, sorry. Can I Can you just
Go on to the question.
>> Okay. My question focuses on the
takeaway from Dante's Divine Comedy and
the Great Books. Specif- uh specific uh
specifically the argument that we can
only move closer to the divine, unlock
our imagination, and find the motivation
to achieve greatness by directing our
love toward another human soul. How does
this framework account for the
individuals who find this exact same
spiritual and creative uh awakening
through nonhuman subjects? For example,
consider someone who grew up isolated
without supportive parents or an
interest in romance, but who form a deep
profound attachment to colors, sounds,
or concepts after intense love for
painting, music, sports, or technology
provides the exact same drive and
beautiful imagination. Can that abstract
devotion serves as an equivalent path to
the source? Are they not adding to the
imagination of the universe and
expanding it as well?
>> Okay, this is a really good point. Um
yes, it is true that in Divine Comedy I
say that the way to activate our love,
our connection to the monad, is by
connecting with another person, by
loving that person unconditionally, like
a child or a mother or a partner.
But what if you are for the reason
alone in the world?
Uh and you are non-verbal. You express
yourself through colors.
And
um
um you can still connect to the monad.
The monad is still in you.
Okay? And you're right. There are lots
of people who are like that, like
Vincent van Gogh, who who produced
tremendous artwork.
Okay? So, the point is that
anyone and everyone can produce great
beauty in the world because of our
connection to the monad. The question
is, as a society, how tolerant, how
generous, how loving are we? Okay? The
more generous, the more tolerant, the
more loving we are as a society,
the greater our creativity. And so, the
example I use would be autistic children
in schools.
I have researched autistic children.
They're not that different from you and
me.
They just have limited emotional
regulation. Meaning like they make
noises in class. But teachers don't
accept that. They're like, "No, if
you're making noises in class, then you
are a problem. Therefore, you should be
on medication."
Okay? So, so that's the society that we
live in today, which is extremely
intolerant, which is extremely um
selfish, very individualistic. And so,
if we are truly to
uh love every child, then we need to
change, transform our society that is
much more loving and generous. Okay?
All right. You want to go ahead?
>> Uh
Which part?
Okay. Professor, thank you for
everything you have done and what you
continue to do. In your lecture, Trump
world order, you discuss a potential
grand plan being carried out by Trump.
From my understanding, you believe that
the failures of the US in the Middle
East may ultimately lead to a decline of
the US empire globally, but the rise of
map the American nation in this
scenario, US will be forced to retreat
and return focus on the Americans where
there is an abundance of natural
resources. Being forced to retreat, the
American global empire is hurt
significantly, but it may be better for
the actual citizens of America. By
focusing internally, America will stop
overextending itself abroad, which will
actually help the country. Do you truly
believe this is Trump playing 4D chess,
or is this just a lucky result where
America basically stumbles into success
in the Americans? Is there an unknown
party behind Trump that is driving him
to make these decisions?
>> Okay, Trump is not playing 4D chess,
okay? Trump is stupid. He's playing 4D
chess in American politics where he's
trying to get a third third term, okay?
That's what he wants. But the idea that
Trump has this grand vision
how to make America great again, that
doesn't really work, okay? What
America's doing what he's doing is this
is a how an empire behaves in decline.
An empire would before would prefer to
control the world through soft power.
And that this is true for the past few
decades where America could control the
world through Hollywood, through um
newspapers like the New York Times,
through an image that America is a
benevolent uh
power, okay? And for the longest time
that was the case. But now that the
world is turning against America,
America has no choice but to use force
to make people obey its will. When you
do that,
eventually the world is going to unite
against you, okay? So this is not about
America shifting strategy, making
America great again. This is about an
empire in decline will always use force
in order to maintain its advantage over
the world.
The problem with this is that once
um
you leave the world, once you retreat
back into your own territory, then the
conflicts among the elite um, become
internalized. So, before the conflicts
could be
um, exported, projected overseas.
Okay? So, we do the conflicts
internally. Once they retreat back, then
they're forced to fight each other.
Okay? And who are the people behind
Trump? Well, it's the people who want to
use American power in order to promote
their own interest. And this includes
um, oil companies like Exxon. This
includes
uh, Silicon Valley who want to create an
AI surveillance state.
Okay? This includes the
military-industrial complex that wants
to expand itself.
Okay?
Okay, this is from Carlos.
>> A lot of conceptions that I hear in your
classes about social economics and
materialism remind me of Karl Po-
Polanyi's thoughts. Do you know his
writings? Are you inspired by him in
some way? Do you think China was some
way able to surpass its elite
corporations of the Western model and
achieve some fair wealth distribution
and energetic transition? Is China's
elite also ruled by secret societies?
>> Okay, so China's elite is not ruled by
secret society, it's ruled by certain
families. Okay? This is very different
because families don't have
eschatologies, they have bloodlines.
Uh, secret societies do have
eschatologies, meaning there's less
energy in China. China's just interested
in maintaining its stat- the status quo.
Whereas secret societies are interested
in in achieving certain eschatologies,
okay?
Um,
will China be able to surpass
its uh, elite corporations of the
Western model and achieve some fair
wealth distribution and energetic
transition?
No, okay?
No.
Um, China is on the decline.
And this is something that cannot be
averted. Listen, I personally think that
China is is a historical accident.
There are many things about about China
that should have been destroyed a long
time ago. But because China has been
historically isolated from the rest of
the world, China has been in East Asia
protected by the sea, the mountains,
great wall,
um it really was not in competition with
the rest of the world. Okay, so I'm not
really that optimistic about China.
>> [clears throat]
>> Okay, Mark.
>> Dear Professor, thank you for your
lectures. They have shaped the way I
think and approach new things I learn. I
recently wrote an essay on
uh Serbia that develops a model I
believe may resonate with some of the
themes you teach. If you happen to have
the time to read it, I would be honored
to hear your thoughts, especially on
whether the framework feels coherent and
useful.
>> Okay, so this is from Mark and I did
read the essay, okay? And the essay is
about how Serbia can try to navigate,
negotiate, and balance the different
powers that surround it, including
Russia, including Europe. Um and it's a
very interesting point.
Um the point I will make is that if you
really want to know how resilient a
society is,
don't worry about how carefully it
navigates diplomacy, okay? You should
ask yourself three questions.
Is this society energetic?
Meaning do people in the society work
hard? Do they take work seriously?
Second is, is this society open-minded?
Meaning is it willing to learn from its
mistakes? Is it willing to be humble and
innovative? The third question is, is it
cohesive? Meaning that there's a
coherent ethnic identity that binds
people together and makes them want to
sacrifice
uh themselves for each other, okay? If
Serbia is answering these three
questions, then Serbia, no matter what
it does, will have a good future.
Okay, I don't know enough about Serbia
to comment,
uh but those are the three questions you
want to ask.
And everything else is not really that
that important. All right, this is from
Wild Encounters. Why are people obsessed
with games? Why are games such a useful
framework for understanding ourselves
and our world? Can a game still be
considered a game if it has no
limitations, only players and
incentives?
Uh yeah, this is a really interesting
uh question.
Um so, I use game theory as a way to
frame human behavior. Okay? But it
doesn't necessarily mean that people are
less
like are you are themselves using game
theory. Game theory just helps me make
certain predictions about the world.
Okay, that's my first point. My second
point is that um games is a way for us
to socialize with each other.
Okay? And
I don't know what what what it is, but
um we live in a world in which
status really matters. But this is this
is not always been historically true.
So, you go back, you know, a few
thousand years when most of the world
was actually matriarchal.
Okay? That was not a game-based society.
Matriarchal societies tend to be very
cooperative.
And it really it really is about balance
and harmony, making sure everyone gets
along. Now that we moved to a patriarchy
and where status is zero-sum game, then
you're forced to play games in order to
achieve status, okay?
So, games aren't the natural state of
humanity. They're a natural state of
humanity for now, but not in the past
and maybe not in the future, okay?
All right, this is from Adeel.
>> Uh Professor Jordan, thank you again for
your Zarathustra lecture lecture and
your broader work on civilizational
strategy. One thing I appreciate about
your analysis is that it takes seriously
the psychological and historical stories
societies tell about themselves, not
just economics or military capacity.
Lately, I've been wondering whether a
lot of modern geopolitics is really
about preserving civilization meaning
and legitimacy. America still depends on
the story about liberalism, liberal
liberalism, freedom, and historical
progress. China depends on the idea of
national rejuvenation
after humiliation. Russia sees itself as
a civilization with a spiritual and
historical mission distinct from the
West. Iran draws on Kabbalah,
martyrdom, Shia Shia, and other Persian
memory through the
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Let us skip to the last part, okay?
>> Okay. So, my question is, how do you
think civilizations can tell when their
founding narratives are still helping
them remain coherent and
reality-oriented versus when they those
same narratives begin insulating them
from reality and pushing them towards
self-deception?
>> Okay. So, I think that the best
civilizations
um the strongest civilizations are those
that have stories
that are universal, that they're able to
connect with other cultures, that
they're able to transcend time and
space. And that's why these four
particular civilizations, America,
Russia, Iran, and Israel are so powerful
because their stories resonate across
time and across space. America is one
fundamentally based on the individual,
freedom of the individual to pursue
his or her ambition, right? Russia is
about community, tradition, orthodoxy.
Iran is about sacrifice, about
eschatology. Israel is about covenant,
about history.
And these themes resonate throughout
time and space.
And that's why right now we're seeing a
conflict between among these four
different traditions
to see who will win. It's not really
clear to me which will also which
story will ultimately triumph, okay?
All right.
Francisco.
>> Okay. Hello, Professor. A fundamental
>> sorry, sorry. You You know what?
Um
Okay, so the question is
um
is there a fine line between stories
that unite and stories that maybe blind
you
from the larger reality?
And
um I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I
I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I
I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I
the more it's able to transcend time and
space.
Okay? And that's why, and this is really
interesting, is let's just say
the entire world is destroyed tomorrow.
10,000 years from now, humanity will
build itself.
Guess what, guys? You have the same
narrative, the same stories, the same
conflicts between freedom and tradition,
between history and the future, okay?
This is what humanity is finally
finally about. We're trying to work out
the stories that we tell ourselves.
Okay?
All right, this is from Francisco.
>> Okay.
Um a fundamental question about a
pattern under global perspective, and
one that intrigues me concerning the
issue of civilization. From other videos
of the past about history, from the
evolution of humankind and the tragedy
of writing, to the patri- patriarchal
shift and suggestions that the
Indo-European victory brought about, as
well as the expansion
>> you can you just can you just read the
question?
>> Yeah. Given this, in your opinion, what
are the benefits of civilization and
empire, or are they inherently evil and
anti-human?
>> Okay, stop. Okay, all right. Okay. So, a
major problem with how history is
taught, how we think about the world is
we apply labels to things, okay? Like,
good, bad, beneficial, not beneficial.
That's not how history works, okay?
History works in
um [snorts] cycles. Rise, fall, up,
down. Civilization
um
and then barbarity, okay? There's
nothing good or bad about these things.
It's an earthquake. We don't say it's
bad, is it good? It's a storm, is it
good or bad? It's just part of the world
we live in. So, stop assigning values
and labels to these things and accept
accept that there's a pattern to these
things.
And our wor- our role our purpose in
this world is to navigate these
patterns, to seek our own individual
meaning in this world, okay? The world
could collapse tomorrow. That doesn't
that doesn't that that that that doesn't
absolve you responsibility to be a good
teacher, to be a good parent, to be a
good neighbor.
Okay? Focus on on what you can do
individually and and don't give labels
to these things. Is America good or bad?
America is just America. Is Russia good
or bad? It's just Russia, okay?
Just keep that in mind.
Okay? This is from from Iran.
>> Isn't there's a possibility that there
are more nation-states with culture and
the popular cohesion that can
effectively combat the international
capital elites that we imagine. For
instance, Iran is an extreme case of the
resilience, but recently Spanish Prime
Minister and South Korean President have
been vocally criticizing Israel
anti-humanitarian actions. Assuming that
is this is the case, do you see your
predictions more or less unchanged or do
you think they need to be corrected to
be less extreme?
>> This is very important, okay? Yes, I do
oversimplify
like my analysis.
The world is extremely complex. There's
like a million data points you can
choose from. I choose from like a few.
Okay? And you're exact exactly you're
exactly right in that I need to consider
more factors, more possibilities, and
more data points.
Uh and I will in the future. It's just
like what's really important for me is
to first build a framework, the
skeleton,
and then work from there, okay?
And that's why I do what I do. Because
you always want to start with a
framework. When a framework allows you
to make better observations.
Don't be too concerned about being
factual.
And this is an argument I'm going to
have with a lot of people where, you
know, like I'm so obsessed with making
predictions that I'm not very factual.
Well, what's important is to first build
the
framework, okay? The skeletal the
skeleton, and then build from there.
Whereas if you just focus on the facts,
it doesn't really get you that many
places, okay? So, you're actually right
that I need to consider more data
points, and I need to make my arguments
more nuanced and more subtle, and I will
in the future.
All right. Uh
this is from TXC.
>> Yeah.
Uh
Professor Chow, your game theory
approach consistency drives toward a
coherent conclusion of US decline,
Chinese uh vindication, Iranian and
resilience. In the spirit of the brutal
skepticism you ask for, what specific
12-month outcome, concrete and
falsifiable, would prove your
macro thesis of structural degrowth
decline wrong?
>> This is a great question. I want to
thank you so much for this question.
This is exactly the sort of question I'm
looking for from my audience, okay? Yes,
because I'm always looking to invalidate
my theory. So, what could happen in the
next 12 months that would
uh
destroy my prediction? Okay. All right.
So, um the US midterms midterms is
something that I can't really predict
what happen.
Okay? It's entirely possible the US
midterms will surprise me in a way
that will have to change my predictions.
I don't know how it will surprise me,
but it's possible, okay?
Uh if Trump were to die tomorrow, that
would change a lot of my predictions,
okay? Because I'm not predicting that
Trump will get a third term.
Okay?
If Trump were to die tomorrow, that
would change the entire
uh world. Um
if the Democratic Party in the United
States picked a leader who was as
charismatic as Trump, who was
revolutionary as Trump,
then I would think that my entire
worldview is wrong. That we can avert
the collapse of history. That America
could regenerate itself.
Unfortunately, I think the most hopeless
part of the United States right now is
is the Democratic Party. If the
Democratic Party were to say, "You know
what? Screw this elitist politics. Let's
get rid of Obama. Let's get rid of
Clinton. Let's have a real democracy and
pick a leader from the grassroots who
could lead us forward."
That I would I would think would be the
greatest thing in the world, okay? Would
that ever happen? Probably not.
Okay? Keep on going.
>> Is there a prediction you made in the
last 18 months that contradicted your
directional thesis? Lately, uh cyclical
uh cyclical history models, Athens,
Rome, tend to project present onto the
past to pattern match. How do you
account for drastically different inputs
today? AI labor displacement, climate
change, space race, etc. in your model.
What's your confident that our current
transition is a historical analog via
via truly uncharted territory? Thank
you.
>> Okay.
So, um
for me the question is, do we believe
that we are truly in a new age of
humanity
where AI could lead us to a new future?
Or is it possible that we discount the
complexity and the sophistication of
ancient civilizations like the Athenians
and the Romans?
Is it possible that they also had
technology that they thought could be
life-transforming
and which would allow them to transcend
history?
Um I think that it's much more likely we
ignore the sophistication of the past
and overemphasize our own
sophistication. There's nothing about AI
uh that tells me that we're heading
towards a new future. I think AI is just
another hocus pocus hallucination meant
to fool us into obedience. And then
there might also be an alien invasion,
okay? So, there's nothing really about
the world that we live in that I think
makes us distinct distinct from the
past.
All right. Okay, from there.
>> I've watched every single one of your
videos over the last year. Some of them
two or three times. I'm curious as to
why there is not nearly no mention of
white supremacy and structural racism
woven into historical and contemporary
analysis. Quite literally, I do not
think the words white supremacy have
been said once. Does geopolitical
geopolitical game series, uh supersede
white supremacy and structural racism.
Do the latter function more as a tool of
domestic management of nation rather
than a cohesive fabric throughout the
world? Do you view them as identity
politics more so than pertinent issue of
our times?
>> Okay. So, um
white supremacy does exist.
Um socialism does exist. I know because
I grew up in Canada.
And if you grew up in Canada as an
immigrant, there's a lot of white
supremacy. There's a lot of social
racism in Canada, even though they won't
admit it, okay? The reason why these
things exist is this is an outgrowth of
empire. This is an outgrowth of the
stories, the narratives that bind a
nation together.
Okay? So, a lot of what's happening in
the world today is for the longest time,
white people were in charge. Everyone
want want to be white. And then you have
the rise of China. You have the rise of
a multipolar world. Um and then these
countries, the United States, Canada,
Europe, they became much more decadent,
much more corrupt. And
and then they start to see their white
supremacy decline relative to other
cultures. And they didn't like that.
Okay? But I don't like to frame it as
white supremacy because that's not
that's not the root of the problem. The
root of the problem is just empire,
imperial arrogance, hubris,
civilization. Okay? So,
I mean, would Chinese supremacy be
better than white supremacy?
Would Japanese supremacy be better than
white supremacy? I don't necessarily
think so. Okay? It's just like, you
know, we are part of a culture. It is
right and good for us to be proud of our
culture. And to think that we should be
that we are superior in many ways.
That's what often leads to cultures to
greatness. Okay? So, there's always
going to be a struggle over supremacy,
and this is what leads to conflict.
Okay? So, yes, white supremacy does
exist, but again, I don't think that's
that's the root of the problem. The root
of the problem is that
um people want to belong in community,
and people want want to believe that
their stories in this community are more
legitimate than other stories.
Okay? And to ask people to just be
completely open-minded and be
non-racist, I think goes against human
nature.
All right. This is from
Sean.
>> Hello, Professor Jones. Thanks for all
that you do. I have a layered question.
You talk about Plato's caves a lot, and
it mostly makes sense to me, but I get a
little confused about the illusion part.
Is the material world itself the
illusion? As in one's own hand, the
device on which I'm writing this, the
building, etc., or is society with its
arbitrary rules the illusion? As if
these things aren't real, why do you do
they impact and influence us on such a
deep level? Thank you again, Professor.
I didn't think I was very interested in
history or geopolitical speculations
until watching your Corgis courses. So,
I'm very grateful to you for living your
truth and your family for inspiring you.
Take care.
>> Okay. Yeah, okay. So, first of all,
society is a complete illusion.
Okay? When you come to school, they
you're just taught nonsense. You're
taught all this illusion.
Okay? What allows society to function is
the fact that you comply to the rules,
which are illusions. Okay? So, the point
of school, the point of media, the point
of culture is to make you believe that
these illusions are real.
And you want them to be real because if
they're if they're not real, then you
can't you can't really function in uh
society. So that's that's pretty obvious
to people, okay? The social rules are
uh
are just illusions.
And we know they're illusions because
um once you
recognize these illusions, that they're
illusions, these taboos are just
illusions, it allows you to better
navigate society, okay? So last semester
we talked about Frankism, Jacob Frank.
That's what he teaches his followers.
Look, everything around you is just an
illusion.
Okay? Do what you want. And once you are
able to enforce your will on other
people, you can achieve what you want
because people are just surrounded by
illusions, okay? They they they don't
yield to what they believe in. So it's
very So it's very easy for you to impose
your own illusions on other people.
Okay?
Um so but the deeper question is, is
this material world an illusion?
And it is an illusion. What is real, and
I keep on emphasizing this in in in this
class, is that it's consciousness
that is real.
Our hands, our eyes, these are the
illusion. But that's a very hard thing
to appreciate, okay? That's why we have
sick societies. That that that's why
there's these mystery schools in ancient
Greece because to convince someone that
your mind is more real than your head,
they think you're insane.
Okay? But once you're able to to make
this
divine or mental leap, your entire world
changes, okay? Now you're able to access
truth, really. But the reality is that
99% of us will not be able to make this
um
realization, okay? To discover for
yourself that, oh my god, it's my
consciousness that is real. Everything I
see around me, this material world,
these buildings, this money,
this wealth, it's all just a fake, okay?
All right. I've been able to do so, but
um it's hard, okay?
This is from Lazar.
>> Yeah. Hello, Professor John, a new
subscriber here looking forward to
reading more of your geopolitical
analysis. I wanted to ask, are you going
to maybe cover the future of Europe and
Balkans in one of your analysis?
It is a region that was the most
unstable in Europe, at least in recent
history. When talking about the big
players, you also mentioned how the
smaller regions and subregions relate
towards Russia, China, US, like South
American parts of African smaller Asian
countries, etc. Recently, China has been
kind of using Balkans as an entry into
Europe with their infrastructure
investments. Right after Trump's and
Putin's visit to China, president of
Serbia also visited China and received a
medal from Xi and only 12 other leaders
received. Also, the visit was on the
headlines of Chinese media, too.
>> Okay, yeah. So, exactly, right. The
Balkans is his- historically one of the
most one of the most important and
volatile regions of the world. So, the
Middle East is probably the most
volatile, but the Balkans are also very
volatile for very similar reasons, okay?
One reason is just the geographic
um necessity of the Balkans.
Uh
it is an access point to many
continents.
Uh second is the
religious conflict in the area. You have
many different religious groups fighting
for control over that area. And the
third is the historical animosity built
up over the centuries of conflict. So,
we can we can expect that the conflict
between Russia and Europe will convert
again in the Balkans. But I I don't know
enough about the area to comment
specifically.
Okay? I was expecting major conflict to
arise in that region,
um as a proxy war between Russia and
Europe.
But the specifics I I don't really want
to discuss, okay?
Again, in the future, what I want to do
is explore more of the world and really
try to understand the different
uh communities in this world.
Okay.
All right.
Uh keep on going.
>> Yeah.
If Tucker Carlson left Fox over the two
2020 election domination trial and he
say Maduro Maduro was captured to
testify that they helped trigger the
2020 election, what did you and Tucker
discuss off air after he got emotional?
Thought on Larry Johnson and other CIA
agents uh agents and boomer
analysts' criticism toward yourself. And
I agree, your great books list is great,
but more sources and any channels you
recommend would be great. Seems you draw
or are tapping to a similar vein as
simulated
Lavendan in regard to the links between
Kabbalah, Hollywood, and AI. Thanks
again, Professor. Love your work. Uh
looking forward to seeing your next
chapter. Best of luck.
>> So, I was on Tucker Carlson's show uh a
couple months ago.
And he got very emotional because
I think that he is an American patriot.
I've always admired and respected Tucker
Carlson, even though politically we
don't align, okay? He and I will
disagree a lot on politics, but I admire
the fact and I respect the fact that he
loves America and he's fought very hard
to protect what's best about America,
especially its civilization, especially
its culture. He's been very consistent
about this.
Okay? And so, um for a few minutes when
the show ended, we discussed the fact
that American culture is being erased.
How
um the very essence of American
civilization, what made America great,
was really Christianity
uh and European civilization. And
because of DEI, because of immigration,
um a lot of this is being eroded. And
that's a very bad thing
for uh for America. And I agree with
that.
Um so, what I admire about Tucker
Carlson is that he's been very
principled in his viewpoint. And he's
been fearless and courageous
in fighting for what he believes in,
including maintaining American
civilization, which is Christian and
white and European. Also,
he's been very consistently anti-war.
And that's cost him a lot. In fact,
there's talk that because of his
anti-war stance, his his he doesn't
believe that America should be fighting
this war in Iraq. There's talk of him
getting arrested.
Okay? So, I I think I've always admired
Tucker Carlson. I think he's an
extremely courageous man, even though we
don't agree. I know that Larry Johnson,
another man I also respect a lot, he has
been criticizing me. A lot of people
have been criticizing me. And quite
honestly, I don't pay attention to the
criticism so because I don't want to be
a YouTube star, okay? I don't want to be
a social media influencer who spends all
his time arguing with other social media
influencers. I want to be an educator. I
want to teach people how to think for
themselves. Okay? And that's why I don't
involve myself in arguments with other
people, okay? Larry Johnson is someone I
I admire a lot. I've watched a lot of
his interviews. I agree with a lot of
his sentiments. I don't know I don't
know what he said about me. And quite
honestly, I don't care. Okay? The fact
that he doesn't like me, the fact that
he criticizes me doesn't really impact
the way I perceive him. Because what I
care about are opinions, okay? What I
care about is analysis. And I sort of
like ignore the personalities behind
that, okay?
All right.
Um Julian?
>> Yeah. Thank you very much, Professor,
for your lectures and for understanding
our world universe better. My question
would be about your theories that secret
societies don't understand that they do
transpiracies theories in the game
theory 26. The concept you use in that
lecture I find very interesting. But
more interesting would be when you add
to this concept the fallen angels, uh
reptiles, gang giants, dragon, lost
ancient civilization, uh Tartaria, etc.
All these conspiracy theories together
to predict our universe.
>> Look, okay. There's a lot of things I
don't know, okay? I'm very interested in
the idea of lost civilizations. They
must exist.
Okay? It doesn't make sense to me that
you know we only have like 10,000 years
recorded human history, but we have but
we've been around for 200,000 years in
our current state, okay? Our current
minds, our current
um
mental development. We've been around as
modern humans for 200,000 years. So
there have been there must have been
other civilizations in place, okay? If
you look at the Amazon, if you look at
um the Grand Canyon in America, if you
look at
Antarctica, there's reason to believe
that there have been other civilizations
before us.
Okay? So I'm very interested in that.
I'm very interested in the concept of
fallen angels, I I I the Nephilim, okay?
There might be some in in in
dimensional reptiles who rule us. I'm
open to these possibilities, but right
now
um I haven't found enough evidence to
discuss them, okay? I'm very much on my
own journey to discover the truth.
And I'm open-minded about these things,
okay? Uh can you keep on reading, Alan?
>> Uh hi, John. You said multiple times
that Israel and Japan will dominate the
region. Israel will achieve the greatest
greater Israel project, and Japan will
rebirth from its ashes.
Uh the greatest Israel project, if I
understood what you said in the lecture,
I didn't rewatch your lectures, so it's
based on my memories. The US will launch
a ground invasion of Iran. They will
lose, and the process both the US and
Iran will be destroyed. The GCC will be
destroyed, and two, since it is just a
creation of empire and is not
sustainable. Uh CENTCOM will be
transformed transferred to Israel. So,
the last player available is Israel,
okay? But, how can Israel achieve its
project if Iran uh and annihilates
Israel? For example, by destroying this
alien nation plants or energy
infrastructures, etc. Israel has nuclear
weapons, so it can use it, but Iran can
build 10 to 20 of them in a matter of
weeks. And we don't know the full
capacit- uh capabilities of Iran. Well,
we can see what the US and Israel are
capable of. We can also add that Israel
is energetic as has high fatality rate,
etc. But, it doesn't really matter if
the country is wrecked. So, I'm
perplexed about your take.
>> Okay.
I don't understand why Iran would want
to destroy Israel.
Iran wants to survive. Iran wants to
remove the United States from the Middle
East. Iran wants to unite the Muslim
world. Those things make sense, but what
Why would Iran want to destroy Israel?
For what purpose? I don't understand
that.
Just because of animosity? That's not
how geopolitics works, guys, okay? There
has to be some very specific reason
for why Iran want to destroy Israel. You
look at what's happening, Iran is
directing most of its attention against
the UAE. Why? Because the UAE,
from the Iranian perspective, it is an
um
ab- abomination, okay? It is sacrilege
what the UAE is. It is demonic, okay?
The Iranians hate the I think the people
in the UAE far more than they hate
people in Israel,
okay? And the Americans.
So, I don't understand why Iran would
want to destroy Israel. Also, why would
Israel want to use a nuclear weapon
against Iran?
For what purpose?
Yeah, I would I understand that if
Israel were to nuke Iran, Iran could
build nuclear weapons and then go nuke
Israel.
But, why would Israel want to nuke
Iran?
Israel wants to weaken Iran,
but
why would it need to use nuclear weapons
to weaken Iran? Wouldn't you be
better off destroying reservoirs,
waterways,
energy infrastructure?
Okay? I don't understand what the
purpose of a tactical nuclear weapon
would be, okay? Now, people have
discussed the possibility of using a
tactical nuclear weapon to destroy
underground missile bases. Yes, but
there are a lot and lots of underground
missile bases scattered throughout Iran.
You don't have enough nuclear weapons to
destroy these these missile bases,
okay? So, I don't understand the logic
of this. I don't believe Iran cares
about Israel enough to commit suicide,
okay? If you go against Israel, Israel
will use nuclear weapons against you.
And why would Iran want want want want
want to cross that line if it means the
destruction of the civilian population?
Okay?
And then Israel doesn't really need to
destroy Iran. Israel needs to remove the
United States from the equation and then
deal with Iran at a later stage,
okay? It wants to weaken Iran to a point
where Iran has to spend all its time
rebuilding itself.
And if And so, my argument is that if a
war between Iran and United States
reaches a point where United States is
forced to send millions of ground troops
into Iran, it's going to destroy both
places, both the United States and Iran.
The The only person left standing will
be Israel at the end. Okay? That's my
argument. I still maintain this belief.
Okay, keep on going.
>> [clears throat]
>> Two, Japan as a missed dominant force in
Asia. In one of your lecture about South
Korea, you said that the country will
collapse because of its low fertility
rate. But, it is the same for Japan. The
population is old and the young don't
want to make children. The most dominant
industrial power in the region is China.
Okay, China is an hallucination of an
hallucination with low fertility rate,
obsessed with money, no uh stock
uh s- uh
s- s- s- s-
>> Okay, I I I understand what you're
saying. All right. All right. So,
um when I make predictions, I look at
several factors. One factor that I look
really closely at is resilience. Okay?
So,
if things are the same, yes, I
understand China will dominate, Japan
will decline. But, the thing about
history is that there's always change.
There's always these cycles. And if the
world is heading towards disaster, which
I think it is heading towards disaster,
I ask myself, which nation states will
be resilient?
In that they will The people will most
likely stand together and make changes
necessary in order to overcome this
adversity. And historically, it's always
been uh Japan. Okay? Japan, in the in
the 12th, 13th century, was able to
survive two Mongolian invasions. 19th
century, when they were being invaded by
the Western powers, they uh underwent
the Meiji um
restoration and became an industrial
power in about 20 30 years time. After
World War II, when they were completely
destroyed by the Americans,
they came together, we changed their
political and industrial system. Before
they were That's something called the
Zaibatsu system, which is basically
monopolies, industrial monopolies. After
World War II, they got rid of those
things.
They ate the rich,
and then reindustrialized,
and in about 20 30 years time, they
became the most industrial They became
the most They became the most advanced
industrial economy in the world. Okay?
So, the Japanese have a history of
resilience, of making changes when when
their survival is threatened. And that's
why I think that Japan will probably do
it again.
Whereas, I I've not seen an instance of
China being resilient. [music]
Okay? I have not.
Okay, can I go on?
This is the last question.
>> Thank you, Professor, for all the
lectures you posted. Also, honorable
mention, the YouTube algorithm that
managed to draw a lot of us in the
beginning to create a critical mass of
viewers to start the hype. One question.
If you would need to move permanently to
another country in the next 6 months,
what would be your top 10 and why?
>> Okay,
um
first of all, because I have a family, I
have three kids, I would not make any
changes lightly. Okay? I would prefer
not to move unless I was entirely sure
that there's a better option for me.
Okay?
But, let us say for the for the reason,
tomorrow I have to make that the move.
Where would I go? Well, some countries
that come to mind would include Botswana
in Africa,
because it's it's like far enough from
everywhere. It's a It's a pretty stable
society. Okay? So, Botswana is something
to consider. Then you have Chile,
uh in South America.
I would consider New Zealand, possibly.
Um Malaysia.
Okay? So, these are four places I would
consider if for the reason tomorrow
World War III breaks out and Europe is
on fire, America's attacking everyone,
America's in civil war. Um
There's lot lots of conflict in East
Asia between Japan and China, who knows,
okay?
All right. Okay, so that's it for
the um
um
founding members and that took us a lot
of time, guys, okay?
Um so I'm I'm going to I'm I'm I'm going
to try to do some YouTube uh
questions for another 10 minutes, okay?
And then we'll break because it it it
it'll be impossible for me to get
through all of the YouTube questions.
All right. Okay, so this is from Joyce
live.
Um space.
What's my theory of space?
I personally don't think space matters.
I personally don't think we'll ever get
to the moon.
I don't think we'll be able to mine
asteroids for resources. I think society
will collapse much
more quick quickly than we assume, okay?
We we don't have the time, energy, the
resources to go conquer the moon, okay?
I think the space race it's all just an
illusion. Space race, AI,
alien invasion, they're all just lies
perpetuated by the elite. I I I pay
absolutely no attention to the space
race. And this is strange because I grew
up watching a lot of science fiction. I
love science fiction. I read a lot of
Isaac Asimov, um Ray Bradbury. I watched
a lot of science fiction like Star Trek,
okay? I love that. So I would love it if
we could get to the Mars. We're not
going to Mars, guys, okay? Not going to
happen. I don't care what Elon Musk
says, it's not going to happen. Let's
get to the moon first, okay? Let's get
the men on the moon first.
All right.
How can you explain India's position in
this chessboard of as far as
convergence?
Um
India, look, again, I don't know enough
about India to make predictions.
But, I will say that geopolitically,
India is a very bad position because it
has a large population.
Uh its political system is very chaotic.
And it's very resource
constrained. It doesn't have that much
resources. So, my prediction for India
would not be that optimistic, okay?
Uh but, eventually, I want to go visit
India and discover for myself the
strengths of India.
All right. Um
Why do you think the people of Israel
have been constantly been expelled for
from many countries over the course of
history?
Um the Israelites say it's because
everyone is envious of them, but is that
really true?
If a kid is expelled from 109 schools,
are the schools at fault or is the issue
with the kid? Okay, so this is actually
a question that a lot of people, I
think, are really interested in, okay?
So, let let me spend spend some time to
explain what's going on.
So, the Israelites have the Bible. And
the Bible commands them to be forever
loyal to God.
And over the course of history,
most Israelites have been absorbed into
different communities, like the
Christians and the Muslims, okay?
And a lot convert themselves to
uh
Greek Hellenism or they just abandon uh
Judaism because
um they wanted to to join the elite.
So, it's only been a minority, a very
small minority, that has kept
the Jewish faith alive over
the centuries. As you imagine,
these people are fanatical. Okay, so
imagine like this a small community.
A small community.
>> [snorts]
>> And so,
the main problem is like how do you
endure?
Because their faith teaches them that
what matters is their faith in God.
They're the chosen people.
>> [snorts]
>> How can they endure as a people?
And so, what happened in history is they
basically made a deal with the devil.
And what I mean by that is they made a
deal with local nobility to serve them
in exchange for being able to practice
their faith.
Okay? The deal often goes like this.
Nobility will hire them
as subcontractors to manage their
wealth.
The Jews are diaspora, okay? So, what
they're really good at are trade and
finance.
Also, throughout most of human history,
nobility were not allowed to engage in
usury.
Okay?
Why? Because usury led to often to
destruction of society.
Okay, when you collect interest on debt,
the debt often multiplies to an extent
that no one can pay it off, which often
leads to revolution.
But, the problem is that usury was the
most profitable enterprise you can
you can engage in, okay? So, what they
really did, which was very clever, is
say, "Let's let's get the Jews to go do
it, okay?"
So, the Jews are not allowed to
own property, go to school, but they're
allowed to
engage in usury, basically finance.
Okay?
So, this is the deal that a A of Jewish
communities made with European nobility.
As you can imagine, this is going to be
a problem because when times are good,
it's fine.
But when times are bad,
people are going to get angry.
And who do they blame? They blame the
Jews.
Right? Because it's not the nobility
that's collecting debt from you, it's
the Jews that are collecting debt from
you.
The Jews think they are the chosen
people, so they set themselves apart
from you. They live in different in
their own communities, they practice
their own religion.
And they think they're better than you,
okay? And this is going to lead to a lot
of conflict. So again,
um when times are good, it's fine, but
when times are bad, the Jews always get
blamed. And again, history goes in
cycles.
And so when when when when when when
times are bad, the Jews get expelled
from a certain location and they move
elsewhere where they restart again. But
they don't care because for them, their
mission is to endure, to keep the faith.
Okay?
And over the centuries, they've learned
certain
uh strategies
of how to endure.
Okay? And a lot of this is basically
um segregation.
Where they keep themselves separate from
other people and they basically think
that other people
are dirty or whatever. I'm not saying
all Jews, but like they have these
traditions in place in order to endure.
And a lot and a lot of these strategies
tend to be very extreme.
Okay? And unfortunately, we're seeing
the same um
same pattern emerge again in today's
world where anti-Semitism is now a very
common thing around the Western world.
Okay? Not just because of what Israel is
doing, but because of certain cultural
practices of the Jews.
Okay? That said, I have tremendous
respect and admiration for the Jewish
people because they are first and
foremost intellectual people, a people
of the book, who have contributed many
great ideas to human history. Okay?
All right.
Which branch of studies have a future in
our modern world?
What would you study if you were at the
crossroads of life?
Okay. One advice I give to people is
ignore AI.
Okay? If you want to become a computer
programmer, if you want to go master AI
to make it to become a billionaire,
you're going you're going to be
disappointed.
If you really want to prepare for the
future,
read books. Okay?
Read the great books, but it doesn't
matter you you don't have to read the
great books, just read books.
Because the skill that you will need in
the future is the capacity to think
critically, think independently, and
think deeply about the world. And by
reading books, you can start to engage
in an inner mono- monologue, sorry,
inner dialogue with yourself.
Okay? And that's going to make you much
more imaginative, much more resilient in
the future. So, my best advice is
doesn't matter what you study, but what
what it does matter is to read books.
Okay?
All right.
Um
Could you help help help me read the
next one?
>> Uh
I want Prof to talk about what advice he
would give to his kids in this
situation. We are going to collapse and
the whole system is going to change.
What advice Prof would give to his kids,
how to prepare themselves for upcoming
situations, and show how well you
prepare your kids for the new war world.
I would be delighted to hear professor's
answers to these questions.
>> Okay. So, every day I would just tell my
kids three things, okay?
And that's all I have to do.
Okay, first thing I will say is like, I
will always love you.
No matter what happens, I will always
love you. No matter what you do, I will
always love you. If I die, I will still
always love you, okay?
Just know that. Wherever you go,
wherever whatever you do, I will always
love you and I'll always be with you.
Okay? That's the first thing I I I I
tell my kids. Second thing I I I'll tell
my kids is
I believe in you.
Meaning
whatever you do
will be good.
Just believe in yourself.
Okay?
All right. And the third thing I will
say is
just believe in yourself.
And if my kids understand these three
things, okay? That their parents always
love them no matter no matter what they
do.
That their parents believe in them.
And their highest mission in life is to
believe in themselves, they'll be fine
no matter what.
Okay? So, it's not really about what
university you should go to. It's not
really about how much money you have.
It's really about how you perceive
yourself and your place in the world.
And I want my kids to always believe
that no matter what they do, no matter
what where they go, their parents will
always love them.
Um
Okay, can you can you help me read out?
>> My question for the final exam is, if an
AI civilian state as the end goal, why
is there such a negative feeling in the
general population for AI? What primary
social, political, political, or game
theoretic factors drive this public
resistance, and how does it impact the
trajectory of AI deployment?
>> There is such negativity towards AI
because everyone knows
what the purpose of AI is. The purpose
of AI is to make you as a human being
worthless, redundant. We don't need you
anymore because we have robots, we have
AI.
Okay? And human beings want to feel
they're participating. Human Human
beings want to feel
uh valuable.
Human beings want to contribute to the
greater good. And AI is a system
designed to make you redundant, okay?
Um keep my voice
>> You predicted US-China grand bargain
where China absorbs Americans' 39
trillion steps via stable coins, the
Janian act to maintain the global USD uh
hallucination. However, you also taught
us that the US grand strategy is to
embargo Malacca and use 21st century
warfare economic strangulation to force
Beijing into submission. If China is
already a fragile hallucination of a
hallucination with collapsing consumer
confidence, what American strangulations
could accidentally trigger a total
collapse of the CCP? How can American
extract wealth from the Chinese consumer
if their own choke point strategy
destroy the Chinese state from
within?
>> Okay.
So, this is a really interesting
question. Okay. So, So, I'll make some
So, the comments. The first comment I'll
make is that if you If you're a
hallucination, you don't know you're a
hallucination, okay?
You don't. Um so, objectively, this may
be true, but the players don't know that
it's true. That's the first point I'll
make. Second point I'll make is that in
a game,
your objective is to win the game. Now,
by winning the game, it may cause the
game to collapse, but you don't care.
The point is to win the game. And you'll
use whatever
tools you have in order to win the game.
So, it's possible that this US-China
trade war will end up collapsing both
nations, but that's not the point. The
point is to win the game.
Okay? The point is not to survive the
game. The point is to win the game. And
sometimes winning the game means
destroying yourself. Like committing
suicide, basically.
Uh that's my second point. Um
the third point I will make is that
um
China and America
they need to engage in a sort of
struggle in order to come to an
agreement. Okay? The reason why is that
there's lots of domestic interests
that they have to deal with. So, for
example, if you're Donald Trump and you
want a grand bargain with China, there's
going to be a lot of people opposed to
this because they think that China is
the great threat and that any compromise
with China means selling out the
American nation. Okay? So, you need to
engage in certain conflict and warfare
in order to dissipate or reduce domestic
tension in order to advance a deal.
Okay? Does that make sense? So, I I
understand it's a really dangerous game
they're playing, but welcome to
geopolitics. This is the way the world
works. The people in charge are
psychopaths. Because in order to win the
game, you have to be a psychopath. Okay?
Think about who in this world is
respected. Well, Israel is is respected.
Putin is respected. North Korea is
respected. Donald Trump is respected.
Why? Because they're all crazy.
These people, everyone agrees on is they
could, if threatened enough, they'll
press a button and blow up the world.
Okay? That's what gets you respect in
this world.
The crazier you are, the more legitimacy
you have.
Okay? And that's why the games they're
playing are crazy. Will this lead to the
end of the world? Probably, okay? That's
what That's what I've been teaching you
guys for a long, long time. The people
in charge are crazy. The game they're
playing is crazy. It's going to lead to
the end of the world.
All right.
We're going to do three more questions
because we could be here forever, okay?
But we'll do three more questions and
we'll end the examination. Okay, can you
read, Allen?
>> Yeah. Explain that American needs an AI
civilian state operation strategy uh
Stargate to manage domestic rebellion
against a coming national draft. You
also noted that the current global civil
war pits transactional capital against
an alliance of nationalist, the church,
and tech elite Trump, Thiel, Musk. But
if the tech elites are using
Masonic
a code philosophy to build an arc
anti-Christ
uh technate that strips human free will,
won't Trump's fierce uh fiercely armed
Christian nationalist
base eventually realize they are being
enslaved by the exact system they're
fighting for? Won't the technate trigger
a second American civil war instead of
preventing it?
>> Yeah, this is exactly right.
Um
So, a civil war is going to happen and
there's going to be many different
factions. There's There's going to be
many different reasons why the civil war
happens. But one reason is that there's
going to be a lot of resistance towards
an AI civilian state. This This is
exactly exactly right, okay? Um and
and there's really nothing anyone can do
right now to stop a civil war from
happening, okay? Keep on going.
>> In this recent lecture on putting in
Beijing, you noted that Vladimir Putin
wants Russia to lead the multipolar
world even if it means acting as a
junior partner to China. However, given
Russia's uh fierce historical emphasis
on absolute sovereignty and it self
imagined as the third Rome can putting
strategy generally survive a long-term
future where Russia is economically
subordinate to the Chinese elite that
fundamentally preferred that American
was hot policeman. What is Russia's
exist game if China choose a divorce?
>> Okay, this is exactly correct, okay?
Um, the Chinese don't trust the Russians
because the Russians are extremely
nationalistic. Extreme I mean there's
Russian supremacy, okay? Even though
Russia will pretend to be the junior
partner to China, the Russians believe
they're superior to China. And a lot has
to do with the third Rome eschatology
that
uh they have.
Um, so if there's a divorce, can Russia
survive economically? And the answer is
yes. It doesn't need China. Okay, it
just needs to fight wars. Because if you
think about historically,
how a nation developed wealth was by
conquering other nations, okay? So what
Russia is going to do is move towards a
total war economy and completely focus
on the conquest of its neighbors,
especially uh Ukraine, but also the
Baltic states as well, and then Central
Asia.
Okay, so as long as Russia is able to
maintain its internal cohesion, engage
in all war, then Russia will be fine.
All right, can you hear me all right?
>> Yeah. Hello Mr. Keating, my question is
for the final exam would be plainly
simple. According to the lecture
material, I'm inclined to believe Putin
has a grand plan laid out. What would
happen if Putin would cease being
Russian leader for reason outside of his
control? Would there be individual or
collective effort to follow same
ideology and continue his plan?
>> This is a great question, okay? Um,
so first of all, I think Putin is going
to live a lot longer than people
believe. I think he's going to live
another 20 years. Okay, that that that
that what my that's what instinct tells
me.
Uh he's going to live for another 20
years, okay? We also know what happens
when a great leader
dies.
It it it's very interesting what
happens, okay? So, if you look at um
Genghis Khan
and Muhammad,
when they die,
okay? There's a pattern that emerges,
which is there's at first internal
friction.
Okay? So, the different interests in
Russia get together and they start
fighting over succession. Who succeeds?
And then they decide we cannot possibly
agree on succession. So, what we'll do
is we will just
go to war with everyone, okay? To just
expand outwards.
Okay? Russia will just expand outwards.
Okay? So, you have this massive
expansion that might go on for 10 20
years where they basically conquer
everyone around them because no one is
no one is as militaristic as they are.
But then what happens, and this is
really interesting, is just exhaustion.
Where they either lose or they win, but
everyone's exhausted and then they they
just decay internally, okay? So, I I
myself don't see Russia as having a
great future,
but this is a pattern that emerges if
you look at history. You know, when a
great leader dies, there's internal
friction, internal chaos, which leads to
military expansion overseas in order to
reduce this internal friction, and then
eventually
the empire exhausts itself because it's
fighting too many wars at once.
Okay? And that's the fate I see for
Russia. Okay, guys. Well, we've been all
here for almost 2 hours. We can go on
for another 2 hours, but I don't want to
because I I'm exhausted. Uh yeah yeah
yeah, Vincent.
>> I think I have a final question. Like I
I always wonder like why are we born in
like
up by ourselves? Like why am I Asian?
Why am Chinese? Why am I not a white
guy? Or why I'm not a like people
I'm not a person in another place of the
world. Like, why are we ourselves? It Is
this connected to Mona?
>> Yes, okay. So, why you here? Okay? And
so,
the theory is this.
And there are lots of reasons why, but
but but but let
let me give you a basic theory, okay?
Theory is that
you come to Earth as a soul.
And your soul has a purpose.
And the purpose is always to
um enlighten yourself.
Enlightenment, basically. All right? So,
the
So, you basically up there
decide on a purpose. Your purpose could
be like, I want to experience being
rich.
Or I want to experience
uh being in love. Okay? You always have
a defining purpose
that becomes the core of who you are.
And so, once you have this purpose,
then you're assigned to a place in this
world that allows you to achieve your
purpose. Okay? So, you are who you are
for a purpose. And this purpose is good.
When it's good, it's for you to try to
achieve your purpose.
Unfortunately, what happens in our world
is that because of school, because of
parents, because of society, you're
blocked from knowing your purpose, from
truly pursuing your purpose. That's part
of the purpose as well, because for you
to truly fulfill your purpose, you need
to overcome a lot of challenges and
obstacles, okay?
And
once you achieve your purpose, then you
understand
yourself a lot better, okay? Then you go
back and you're like, okay, now I want a
new purpose.
But maybe you don't want to this
purpose, in which case, well, you do it
again, okay?
All right? And this this is this is the
idea of samsara
in Vedic um mythology. Okay? So, that's
one explanation. There are other ex- ex-
explanations, okay? But, the thing to
remember is that you came here for a
purpose.
You may not remember what your purpose
is, but you can feel what your purpose
is.
And so, what you should always do is
trust your intuition, because that's
what that's what's going to lead you to
your purpose. You're in this You're here
in this classroom as part of your
purpose. I'm here teaching you as part
of my purpose.
Okay? And that's the structure of the
universe.
Does that make sense?
Okay, guys. All right. So, thank you. Uh
enjoy the rest of your life.